this is what they say um
that women are and men must become
completely true right i mean it's
because a man
you talk about there's nothing worse
than being born rich and then just being
rich
the beauty is being [__] dirt poor
and becoming rich completely and all
three of us sitting here have
dealt through that a man has to have
tenacity and go through struggles and
days when you're like i can't [__] do
this anymore but still pop your head up
the next day i'm like all right let me
go back get back in the gym i say
tenacity i say this all the time i say
the best things that ever happened to me
are the worst things ever happened to me
all the trauma and [__] i've been
through in my life are the best things
that ever happened to me because as a
man if you've not had a difficult life
you could not be good at being a man
being a good man and being good at being
a man they're two slightly different
things but to be good at being a man you
need to be have been through so much
[__] that when the matrix deletes your
entire life from the internet and starts
lying about you at mass and people start
doing protests wanting you [__] hung
and they're looking for your family
members and reporters start calling
every ex-girlfriend you've ever had
trying to convince them and bribe them
to lie to come out and say you're
something you're not when they're
genuinely out to put you in jail that
you can sit there and be focused and
stoic enough to go you know what okay
what's the chess board what's gonna
happen who's trying to shoot me right
now nobody okay so it's better than it
was a couple years ago okay so xyz did
and plan through it right you're never
gonna be capable as a man if you've not
had trauma the best man ever have had
trauma if you call a police officer you
need a brave police officer he ain't
going to be brave unless he's been
through [__] yeah he's not going to be
ridiculous he's been through [__] so we
also as a society sit and look at men
but we want well
there's two kinds of societies of
society but the true society of true
women with a brain the actor i want a
man who's strong who's supportive who's
intelligent who financially provides et
cetera then you're going to want a man
to some degree who's been through some
[__] yeah and a man who's internalized
it and use it as a weapon and this is
what i say to people people email me
their long lists of all the bad things
that happen to them and i reply
fantastic
you are so lucky you have all the
building blocks to become
the exact kind of man you want to be if
none of this [__] happened to you when
something else bad happens to you later
you wouldn't be able to deal with it
fantastic he goes no but you know this
this he replied again with more excuses
said why are you making excuses i just
told you what happened to you was a good
thing you need to reframe your mind bad
things happened to batman they killed
his parents do you understand that's why
he's batman you've just told me you have
the building blocks to become the most
you might become top g when i retire
fantastic what are you complaining about
what do i do i said you need to work
take all that trauma if you're truly
heartbroken my friend and we've all been
there as men if you're truly heartbroken
you can't sleep that means you're gonna
get in fantastic shape you better hit
the gym you have nothing else to do just
stop watching youtube stop emailing me i
want pictures of you in the gym get the
[__] work heartbreak's a fantastic
motivator as is depression as his
sadness great look at what's pissing you
off and make sure it never happens again
if you were jacked and rich as [__] she
probably wouldn't have left your ass so
get your [__] together right so this is
so important trauma's such an important
part of being a man and and the matrix
talks of trying to say that trauma is
terrible and avoid trauma or if you get
trauma take a pill and that's
unrealistic trauma's gonna happen to you
and you you as a man need to internalize
it accept it and weaponize it to become
the best version of yourself you can be
and that requires mental strength and
stoicism it does not require
oh and be more emotional if you're more
emotional you're gonna fall apart when
[__] happens you're gonna end up like
logan paul crying your eyes on tv like a
[__] i imagine there's a lot of uh
men that hate you because they have not
done anything with their lives and
you're basically saying clean it up
buddy get it together hit the gym make
something in your life
they want to get rich quick they want
the easy way out and they probably hate
you more than feminists it's interesting
the men who support me online have their
[__] together the men who hate me are
fat
the men who done the takedown videos of
me are objectively
objectively unattractive individuals i'm
not trying to be insulting just
objectively obese unattractive
individuals right people who don't have
their life together it's the same even
more with women you can find 10 women
who are sticking up for me supporting me
they're all beauty queens and then you
find some girl sitting there some troll
sitting in the corner andrew's bad for
women
you know so there's a lot to be said
there right and hate always comes from
below it never comes from above the
people who have their lives together
whether male or female love me the
people who have failed and they know
that the failure is their own fault and
i show i'm a good mirror i reflect their
own failures at them oh yeah of course
they hate me and that's what's happened
here what's most upsetting is as follows
this whole idea of protecting women and
misogyny has been weaponized to attack
someone they don't like these people
saying that we need to get them down to
some misogynist they don't give a [__]
about women these people do you think
they care there's some fat troll so
there's some dude called dads who made a
takedown video of me who just came out
came out actually on my last podcast
turns out he was talking to a 13 year
old girl so he's a fat pedophile so
there's a fat pedophile who did a video
on youtube about me saying that i'm
dangerous for women got 10 million hits
because he's objectively unattractive
saying that he cares about women but
he's a pedophile himself he doesn't care
about women he's jealous of me he's
jealous of who i am in my lifestyle so
he's found something he can use to
weaponize if he can't make up that
[__] and attack me how else can he
attack can't call me broke can't call me
dumb can't call me stupid what can he
call me well he's better than me and
everything but if i take this and
pretend to give a [__] he doesn't give a
[__] i build orphanages in romania i
have a i have a charity that rescues
stray dogs i rep i take time out my life
replying to emails saving people from
suicide what the [__] does this guy do
for anybody nothing but he's the good
person because he gives a [__] no he's
using it as a vehicle to attack somebody
who he knows is his superior and every
single human metric that can be measured
by modern science and he dislikes me for
it all of this is just weaponized care
are we we care so much about they don't
care about [__] anything they don't
care about people they just dislike me
and that's a very different thing it's
all been false in the beginning i've
seen through it all from the absolute
beginning it's a matrix attack and like
i said it's i told you how it happens
youtube strike
meta youtube media media media media
media uber gmail discord skype twitch
boom boom boom boom it's all [__]
coordinated hit piece it's [__] if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
watch the entire podcast click over here
and if you want to be connected with
experts influencers such as kiyosaki
tate connolly parliamentary myself and
others download the app minect where you
get a chance to connect with these folks
by the minute you get to buy the minute
or have face times with them 15 minutes
ask them any questions you may want to
have download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today
[Music]